[MUSIC PLAYING]
CHEN GOLDBERG: Hi.
Good afternoon, everybody.
I'm Chen Goldberg.
APARNA SINHA: And
I'm Aparna Sinha.
CHEN GOLDBERG: And thank
you for joining us today.
It was super exciting
for us to see
Urs presenting the
Cloud Services Platform
today in his keynote.
We started working
on this vision a bit
over four years ago, where we
took our years of experience
in developing applications
and managing them reliably,
and brought them
through the industry
through Kubernetes
and Kubernetes Engine.
We invited community, users,
partners, and customers
to work with us, ensuring
Kubernetes solves
real problems for all users.
The result is that
Kubernetes today
is the industry standard
for managing containers
applications.
It is used by enterprises of
all sizes in their journey
to modernisation, increasing
teams' productivity
and leapfrogging competition.
Last year, we open
sourced Istio,
decoupling service development
from service management,
and it already got significant
traction from the industry,
including first
users in production.
Today, we are bringing those
technologies and a few new ones
together, building an
integrated stack, giving you
application modernization
wherever you are, in the cloud
and on premises.
Our new solution is built
with those four principles
in mind, consistent experience,
centralized control,
agility with reliability
and flexibility.
We'll be using them to
introduce our products.
It will help you understand why
we have built Cloud Services
Platform the way we have,
and what to expect next.
If they sound
familiar to you, it
is because they are already
rooted in Kubernetes.
They are also demonstrated
in many other Google Cloud
Platform products
and solutions today.
You will hear more of them
throughout the next three days.
APARNA SINHA: And
we want you to know
that these principles
are not just principles
for technical design.
They are principles that
enable a customer journey that
starts with you, where you are,
and allows you to transform IT
at your own pace.
We all know that
enterprise IT is complex.
Every customer that I work
with has a mix of custom
developed software as well
as off the shelf software,
and a variety of on-prem
hardware from many vendors.
And across that, they
have to ensure security,
regulatory compliance, and
all of their policies work
seamlessly.
This complexity can
slow businesses down.
In the middle of
this environment,
cloud offers an
opportunity for speed
and competitive advantage.
But without the
right software, cloud
can sometimes add another
layer of heterogeneity
to an already
complex environment.
Cloud Services
Platform is targeting
the 80% of enterprises
that are looking
to enable hybrid cloud today.
They need a way to homogenize
public cloud infrastructure
with what they have on-prem,
connecting and managing it
together.
I see users marrying the
modern with the existing,
so that they can really
enable use cases like these.
They want to have CI/CD--
Continuous Integration,
Continuous Deployment-- across
public and private.
And they want to
be able to manage
compute at the edge, where
they can have low latency,
or for regulatory reasons,
or just for business reasons,
and yet have centralized
intelligence in the cloud.
And then lastly, they
want to be able to consume
the best-of-breed services,
regardless of where they're
running, whether in their
on-prem data center,
in GCP, or in any cloud.
Today, to accomplish
these use cases
requires a lot of fragile,
do-it-yourself integration.
Or, it can result
in a compromise
between consistency and
choice, between agility
and reliability.
Cloud Service Platform is a
different kind of hybrid cloud
software that overcomes
some of these trade-offs,
so you don't have to
make those compromises.
At its core, Cloud
Services Platform
is powered by Kubernetes
and Istio, which
are open source, enabling that
consistency across environment.
But on top of that, this
stack is custom-configured,
enterprise-hardened, tested
and managed by Google,
so you have that
centralized control.
It is also deeply
integrated with GCP services
to deliver the benefits
of Google Cloud On-Prem.
And then, this integration
enables a wide variety
of solutions, such as
CI/CD, across clouds--
also machine learning
and serverless
and a variety of others.
Today, Chen and I are
going to demo for you
exactly how we break some of
the traditional trade-offs
with these design principles.
CHEN GOLDBERG: The
first principle
of Cloud Services Platform
is consistent experience.
We have seen with Kubernetes
how much consistency matters.
The idea of write
once, run anywhere,
pulled users and partners
into its community.
No lock-in to a specific
platform really excites users.
It simplifies things for
developers and operation teams
when they know there is a
certain set of primitives
they can rely on.
Cloud Services Platform
takes consistency further.
Portability isn't enough.
Users are looking for
consistent user experience,
use the same tools everywhere,
where their workloads run.
Their operations
teams would like
to have the same way to
manage the cluster, on-premise
and in the cloud.
Developers would like to
develop, build, and deploy
the application the same
way, regardless of where
the workloads will run.
The SLA team would like to
have the same tools in order
to troubleshoot an issue,
regardless of an environment.
Our customers tell us they
want a consistent experience
of Kubernetes Engine, GKE.
GKE has been GA for
almost three years now,
and users like Kubernetes
Engine, automation,
upstream currency,
and reliability.
It is Google-configured,
managed,
and supported Kubernetes.
They've been asking
us, how can they
get the same capabilities in
their on-prem data centers?
And we are giving our
customers exactly that.
Introducing GKE On-Prem.
It is Google-configured
Kubernetes,
with automated provisioning,
managed upgrades, and security
in your on-prem environment.
When talking with users, this
is when their eyes light up.
The idea that they don't have to
train their teams once or twice
to learn different tool
really excites them.
This is where they are
spending most of their time.
Operation teams having
a single playbook
to manage all of
their environments
is really a
game-changer for them.
Less time spent on
training and integration
leaves more time to innovation,
and increases the team
productivity.
What's even more awesome
about GKE On-Prem,
that it connects seamlessly
to Google Cloud Platform,
and helps you manage a
multi-cluster environment
wherever your cluster is.
And all of them will look
and behave exactly the same.
Let's move to the demo and
see consistency in action.
OK, so here, what
we have already
is that earlier this
morning, my team
provisioned a GKE On-Prem
cluster on this pizza box
server running vSphere.
Voila!
This is all live demo.
And now I will show you how
to integrate this cluster
into your GKE environment and
get that consistent experience.
From the GKE UI, I can go and
register an external cluster.
I will call it the
innovative name West.
And then I will download
this GKE Connect manifest.
Let's look inside it.
What it will help us is to
create that connection to GCP.
Oh, sorry.
So what it has inside,
it has a namespace.
And in addition to that, there
is a service account and role
bindings, [INAUDIBLE] in the
UI in order to access and view
the workloads in the cluster.
We also have here a deployment
of the GKE Connect agent, which
is what we use in order to
create a secure connection
from this cluster into GCP.
Let's apply it.
You can also see
here in this UI,
that GKE is waiting for GKE
Connect connection with Google.
And once it's done, we will see
this change into a check mark.
Yay!
And we'll continue
to the next step.
Here, I have to provide
some more details.
Also, I want to
make sure that we
are talking with the right
cluster from GCP's side.
So I will use a
certificate, provide the IP,
and continue to authenticate.
For the sake of the
demo, I will just
skip authentication for now.
But I can also use a user
token, or leverage an identity
provider, in order to
do basic authentication.
And we are finished.
What we can see right
now, in the environment,
in my GKE environment, I
can see all my clusters,
including this on-prem cluster.
And it is already registered.
But you can also
see that I don't
have any details about it.
Everybody needs to enter
their own user credentials,
and this is why there
is this lock icon here.
This is good hygiene
practice in general,
and it helps us to maintain the
integrity of the environment
and make sure that we have the
right audit logging and RBAC
policies.
I will copy it from
the environment.
And now I will actually get
access into the cluster.
And you can see how I
can see the cluster size,
the number of CPU, and more.
From this point on,
everything actually
behaves exactly the
same as the GKE clusters
you are used to
managing on GKE UI.
Yes.
First live demo.
Yay.
We see the master
version, for example,
which is very important.
Again, another attribute
that we keep consistent
with your GKE environment.
We heard from our customers
this is really important
for them, for the
integration aspect
they have to GKE
and to Kubernetes.
We can see the nodes
that are there.
And like every other GKE
cluster, I can go into the node
and see really
useful information,
such as the pods
running, and resources
available on that node.
So this is just looking
on a single cluster.
But then, GKE actually creates
this multi-cluster single pane
of glass, where I
can see, for example,
all the workloads running
in my environment,
regardless of which cluster
they are running on.
And this is true also
for services as well.
So this is really nice,
getting that visibility
into my environment.
But what's even more
awesome-- and again,
first time doing it onstage--
I will also deploy, from
GCP, for the first time,
into a cluster which is
actually not a GCP cluster.
And it can run anywhere.
We'll go into Deploy.
And we really wanted to make
sure it's simple as possible.
And all I need to do is to
choose the right cluster.
I will click Deploy.
And what do you think?
Dun, dun, dun.
Voila!
Yay!
[APPLAUSE]
And while it really
looks simple,
it's actually not simple to do.
And for us, we heard
from our customers
that they really appreciate
the management capabilities
they have on GKE.
And we want to provide
that wherever customers
are running their workloads.
Back to the slides.
This is a quote
that I really like,
since it captures
really what excites
me the most about the
technology we are building.
You know, I'm an
infrastructure person.
But what excites me is that
we are allowing developers
to really free their time
and focus on innovation.
APARNA SINHA: Awesome.
Consistency is
the building block
for the next principle of
Cloud Services Platform, which
is centralized control.
We all know that
control is important.
But what is different about
Cloud Services Platform
is two things.
Number one, it provides control
not just across clusters,
but across environments,
so across GCP
and other environments.
Number two, it
works out of the box
with your existing
authentication
and other services.
So it doesn't create a trade-off
between control and agility.
As a complement to Chen's
announcement about GKE On-Prem,
we're also really excited
to announce GKE Policy
Manager, which is in alpha now.
This is a piece of software that
allows admins to define tenant
namespaces, as well
as policies that can
be applied across environments.
And these are defined
in a single source
of truth, which could be GCP
IAM, or a Git repository.
The software then automatically
updates all participating
clusters at once, regardless
of where they are.
They could be in GCP, or a
different cloud, or on-prem.
And so it synchronizes
those policies everywhere.
Our first version supports
synchronizing namespaces,
Role-Based Access Control, or
RBAC policies, quota policies,
and more.
And we're going to show
you a demo of that now,
actually using the cluster
that Chen provisioned.
So we can move to
the demo screen.
There we go.
All right.
So first I want to show you what
clusters I have access to here.
I've got actually four clusters.
I'm going to be using
three of them in this demo.
I've got US Central, East
Coast, and this puppy
over here, the West cluster.
I've also set up some watches
on these three clusters.
So here's a watch on East,
here's a watch on Central,
and here's a watch on
the namespaces in West.
And as you can see, there's
really just system namespaces
here today.
As an admin, what I want
to do is, across all
of my environments, I want
to set a set of policies
that apply to all of them.
And I've created
some policies, first
of all, that I'm going to
copy into this directory.
And let me show
you what they are.
So I want each cluster to
have three namespaces--
a dev namespace, a prod
namespace, and a staging
namespace.
And for my SREs, I
want to give them
pod creation access across
all of these three namespaces.
So I've created a pod creator
SRE role binding that,
in this hierarchical
tree, applies to all three
of these namespaces.
But in my dev namespace,
that's the only place
that I want to allow
developers to create pods.
I don't want them to
be able to create pods
in production or in staging.
So I have created this role
and role binding for pod
creation just for the devs,
just in the dev namespace.
Also, I want to make sure that
my test costs don't balloon out
of control, so I'm going
to set a quota policy which
is encapsulated here
in quota.yaml, also
for the dev space.
All right.
This is cool.
Now what I'm going
to do is add that
to an empty Git repository.
So that's going to be my
single source of truth
for all of my policies.
And then I will go ahead
and commit this file.
And as I push this
change, you will
start to see, in
these three watches,
those three namespaces come up.
So we should see an orders-dev,
orders-prod, and orders-staging
namespace come up in
all three clusters.
Fingers crossed.
And OK, it looks like US Central
has got orders-dev, prod,
and staging.
Nice.
And US East does as well.
And here is our pet
cluster here on prem
and on the stage, which has GKE
Connect, the agent that Chen
configured earlier.
And there also we have
the three namespaces.
So you see here centralized
policy management synchronized
across multiple environments.
One last thing I'm
going to show you
is that quota that I created.
I want to make sure that
it's also actually enforced
right here in this cluster.
So I've changed context
to the West cluster,
and I'm going to see if
there's a quota file.
So let's go ahead and open that.
And indeed, there is
a resource quota file,
and it does set a both
CPU and memory quota limit
for what my devs can do.
And so that's it.
That concludes the demo.
In summary, Cloud Services
Platform Policy Management
software allows you to
apply policies across cloud
from one source of truth.
You can kind of think of
it as security and policy
portability.
CHEN GOLDBERG: That
was an awesome demo--
one of my highlights,
the thing I
love the most about
this announcement.
The combination of
consistent experience
and centralized control access
on-prem and in the cloud
is powerful.
But all of this is ultimately
in the service of your business
success.
That depends directly on
developers' productivity
and on their apps
running reliably.
Often, these two
things are at odds.
Developers want to move
fast, but operation teams
would like to make sure
the environments are
enterprise-ready, and they
would like to have less changes.
That brings us to
the third principle
of Cloud Services Platform,
agility with reliability.
Cloud Services Platform lifts
this trade-off with Istio.
Istio is an open platform to
connect, secure, and manage
services.
It takes care of traffic
management, monitoring,
and security.
It does it by raising
the level of abstractions
from VMs, containers,
and ports to services.
This also means
that Istio can work
with uncontainerized
workloads together
with containerized ones.
This week, we are
announcing Istio 1.0,
and its readiness for
production environment.
APARNA SINHA: Woohoo!
CHEN GOLDBERG: This
has two big benefits.
One, it puts more
intelligence in the hands
of the operators, who can now
systematically monitor, secure,
and control services.
The second one, it
relieves the developers
from writing common capabilities
that every app requires,
like monitoring, authentication,
logging, and more.
By decoupling development
from operation,
Istio gives coders their time
back, while not compromising
the reliability aspect,
and gives operations
high-quality common services,
enabling greater visibility,
security, and reliability.
Now we'll go to the
last demo for today.
APARNA SINHA: All right.
So as a developer,
I want to focus
on writing my applications
that actually add value
to my business.
I don't really want
to write a whole bunch
of common services
for auth or monitoring
or logging or other things.
And those things need
to be done, done well,
in their own right.
So Istio actually enables
us to decouple that work
from developers, freeing us
to focus on what's important.
And I'm going to
demo that for you.
Specifically, this demo is
going to show you three things.
Number one, it's an example
of how Istio frees developers
from having to implement auth
in each of their services.
Number two, it's
going to show you
how, as a security operator, I
can apply policy incrementally
to new services, in the
face of existing services,
without breaking them.
And then number three,
I'm going to demo
how Istio enables a
secure-by-default enterprise.
And to do that, I'm going
to be using this application
called the Bookinfo demo app.
It consists of four services.
As you can see,
these four services
are written in four different
languages, also referred
to as a polyglot application.
And each of these languages
can have their own way
of implementing monitoring or
auth or any of these services.
But what we've done here
is we've deployed Istio.
And we've enabled Istio as
an auto-injected on-by-proxy
in each service.
And you kind of see
that with the blue line.
This required zero code changes
from any of the developers.
And out of the box, it
comes with authentication,
best-in-class authentication.
It comes with intelligent
routing and telemetry.
For demo purposes, we
also have two clients.
There's a modern client that's
in the Bookinfo namespace.
So that's going to
be shown in green.
And it's actually going
to get all of the changes
that we make through Istio.
And then there's a red client,
which is a legacy client.
It could be a legacy service
that you have existing.
And it's not going
to be Istio-enabled.
And then what we're
going to show here
is incremental enablement of
MTLS, first in permissive mode
and then in strict mode.
All right.
So we can move over to my
screen so we can start the demo.
Oh, good.
OK.
So for this demo, I'm going
to use the Midwest cluster.
And so we've switched context
to the Midwest cluster.
And just to show you
what's in this cluster,
these are the namespaces.
So Istio is in fact deployed
in the Midwest cluster.
And also we have the
Bookinfo application,
which we were showing
you just on the screen.
But let's take a look to
make sure what deployments
are part of Bookinfo.
And so here you see
there's a client, which
is the Bookinfo
full client that's
going to be generating load.
There are the four services--
the details service,
the product page service,
the rating service,
and three versions of the review
service, so we can do Canary.
And so what we're
going to do is,
the Bookinfo client is going
to be hitting the product page.
But remember I told you
there's also a legacy client.
So let's just take a
look at where that is.
If we just do kubectl
get deployments--
there's this legacy
client that's
not part of the Istio
or Bookinfo namespace,
and it's also going to be
hitting the product page.
Let's first just check
to make sure there's
no policies installed.
And so let's see if
there's any policies.
There's no policies.
And let's also then
get a Grafana dashboard
so that we can take a
look at the traffic that's
hitting the product page.
And so this is the IP address
for the Grafana dashboard.
And I've already gone
ahead and set that up.
So here you see that
there's two QPS of traffic
hitting the product page.
So here we are.
We're looking at the Istio
service dashboard in Grafana,
and we're looking at what's
hitting the product page.
And at the moment, there's
two QPS of traffic,
and it's all non-authenticated.
So there's no client-side
authentication.
Anybody that hits the product
page will get a response,
and you know, it's all 200s.
So now what we're
going to do is we're
going to turn on permissive
MTLS in the Bookinfo namespace.
So what that means is, I'm
going to set up this policy
and then apply it.
Let's take a look at the policy.
So the policy is going
to apply to every service
in the Bookinfo namespace,
and the mode is permissive,
and Istio mutual.
So permissive mode means that
whether the client that's
hitting has MTLS enabled
or not, the product page
is going to go ahead
and accept that traffic.
And so what we should
see, though, in Grafana,
is some of the traffic
is going to be MTLS.
Some of the traffic is
not going to be MTLS,
because we've turned on MTLS
for all services in the Bookinfo
namespace.
OK, so now let's go ahead
and apply this policy.
And it looks like the
policy is created.
The destination rule is created.
And now when we look
at Grafana, we'll
see one QPS of MTLS traffic
from that load generator,
that Bookinfo client that's
in Bookinfo namespace that
has Istio, and then
one QPS of traffic
from the legacy client
that doesn't have MTLS.
OK?
So let's see what happened.
And indeed, you see that
the non-MTLS traffic
has gone down to one QPS.
So this is just the traffic
from the legacy client.
And in addition, we've now got
this additional traffic, that's
also one QPS, that is MTLS.
So this is the MTLS traffic
from the Bookinfo client
that's in the same namespace.
So you see we've gone down
from two QPS to one QPS, one
QPS each of MTLS and non-MTLS.
So this is permissive mode.
That's great.
And the benefit
here was we didn't
break the legacy service.
So the legacy service is still
hitting the product page.
And that's fine.
And SRE can then talk
to the developers
and say, hey, we got to stop
with this legacy service.
Please implement client-side
auth in that legacy service,
because we want everything
to be authenticated,
because this is a
product page that's
got sensitive information.
So now what we're
going to do is we want
to turn off the legacy service.
Turns out it's actually rogue.
And we want to enable
MTLS-only authentication.
We only want services that
have client-side authentication
to communicate with
our product info page.
So this is what the
YAML looks like.
It's very similar,
so it again applies
to the Bookinfo namespace.
But now the mode is strict.
So we're strictly
going to accept traffic
from services, client
services, that understand MTLS.
And so let's go
ahead and apply that.
And here we go.
And so now that
policy's been applied.
And what we should see now
is only one QPS of traffic,
only from the service that's
in the Bookinfo namespace that
has MTLS enabled.
And the other one, the rogue
client, should go away.
So let's see, did that happen?
And it looks like it did happen.
So you see that the blue
service, the traffic
from the unauthenticated,
non-MTLS service
has gone down to zero QPS.
And now we only just have
the one QPS of traffic
from the MTLS-enabled service.
And we can see that together.
So actually, if you want, we
can see the history of this.
Let's just go back 15
minutes, and you'll
see we had both two QPS.
Then we went to one and one,
and now we just have one.
So that's nice.
In summary, without
any code changes,
we have enabled
client-side authentication
across every service in
the Bookinfo namespace.
And also, by the way, we've
turned on security by default.
So if there are any other
services in the future created
in Bookinfo, they're going
to be MTLS-enabled as well.
Those are not the only
benefits of Istio.
We don't really have time to
demo all of the benefits today.
So instead, I've
invited a customer
to speak to you
about how they are
using Cloud Services Platform
to solve real-world challenges.
It's my pleasure,
and please join me
in welcoming Jeff White,
platform architect at eBay,
to the stage.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you, Jeff.
JEFF WHITE: Thank you.
APARNA SINHA: Hi, Jeff.
APARNA SINHA: Welcome.
Thank you for joining
us at GCP Next.
Can you tell us
a little bit more
about your group and
your role at eBay?
JEFF WHITE: Hi.
I'm excited to be here
and share eBay's story.
My group is focused
on building products
to expand eBay's reach to new
markets and market segments.
Last year, we released
a new buying experience
for the Chinese market.
We also released eBay
on Google Assistant.
And we've been
developing AI technology
to enhance these products.
My role is to help build
our services platform.
Our team is responsible for
all aspects of development
and operations, everything
from choosing application
frameworks,
continuous integration
and continuous
delivery, platforms,
and setting standards
for logging,
monitoring, and alerting.
One of our goals is to build
a services platform that
is easy to evolve as our
architecture grows and matures,
and places minimal burden
on individual developers.
A core strategy to delivering
on our product and technology
goals was our decision to
expand to the public cloud
two and a half years ago.
There were many benefits to
expanding to the public cloud.
The key aspects that
were important for us
were global infrastructure,
autoscaling,
and managed services.
These aspects have helped us
quickly build new products,
scale our infrastructure
with our user traffic,
and provide an
optimized experience
to our international customers.
APARNA SINHA: That's great.
And if I understand
correctly, you now
have more than 30 GCP
services that you're using.
JEFF WHITE: Yes.
Pretty much.
We take advantage of GCP
services as much as we can,
and we try to place all our
applications in Kubernetes.
APARNA SINHA: Wow.
That sounds like an
amazing charter, Jeff.
So how's your journey so far?
JEFF WHITE: Fantastic.
[LAUGHTER]
We've learned a
tremendous amount
about building robust
cloud-native services.
Kubernetes and Helm, along
with our internal tools
and standards, have made it
very easy to deploy services.
And we've scaled
our architecture
across multiple dimensions.
We have on the order
of 100 applications,
and they're running a variety
of languages and frameworks,
and these services are deployed
across multiple clusters
running around the world.
APARNA SINHA: Wow.
JEFF WHITE: And of course,
we've scaled our infrastructure
horizontally to match our
traffic and workloads.
But scaling across
these dimensions
presents new
monitoring challenges.
A microservices architecture
shifts the emphasis
from monitoring individual
services in isolation
to monitoring the entire
system as a whole.
When you get paged, the problem
is never your fault, right?
APARNA SINHA: Right.
JEFF WHITE: It's always,
you can't connect
to one of your dependencies,
or some error way upstream has
propagated all the way
to you, and now everyone
is up, trying to figure
out the root cause.
Standardizing monitoring
signals allows us
to monitor across the system.
This allows you to do
things like correlate logs
by trace ID, and
distributed tracing,
so you can inspect the
network call stack.
But these monitoring concepts
require services to collaborate
on consistent standards,
and they become
part of the platform itself.
But adding this logic to our
applications and libraries
makes it difficult to
migrate, especially
in a polyglot environment.
Maintaining a services
platform becomes
exponentially difficult as
the architecture scales.
APARNA SINHA: I see.
I understand.
So how are you dealing
with this complexity
and multi-polyglot
services environment?
JEFF WHITE: Boom!
[LAUGHTER]
So we looked at service
mesh technology,
and we saw the value of
moving these common networking
concerns from our
application processes
to an individual,
independent component.
And we particularly
like how Istio
makes this transparent
to services,
with its strong Kubernetes
integration and sidecar proxy
approach.
So we started experimenting
with Istio earlier this year,
and it was a natural
decision to initially focus
on the observability features--
metrics, traces, and logs.
These provided us with the
biggest initial benefit
while minimizing risk
and learning curve.
And perhaps most
importantly, we would
be able to use the very metrics
provided by Istio to help
us evaluate and fine-tune as we
incorporate more advanced Istio
features.
As part of our
testing, we gradually
increased the size of our mesh
by using an opt-in policy.
And today, we are running
Istio in production.
APARNA SINHA: That's awesome.
[APPLAUSE]
JEFF WHITE: Our mesh contains
about 10 services so far,
and we are progressively
adding more.
And we now have a uniform
and transparent mechanism
of collecting metrics,
traces, and logs.
The Prometheus and
Grafana dashboards
provide us with the key metrics.
We can get an aggregated
view of the overall health
of the entire service mesh,
showing traffic, latency,
and errors, three of the four
golden monitoring signals.
And we can dive into an
individual application
and see those same very metrics.
And we also have Stackdriver
integration working,
and we're continuing to
explore those capabilities.
These tools complement
our existing metrics
and monitoring,
allow us to continue
to refine our
service-level objectives,
and assist us in troubleshooting
live site issues.
And we're now in
a great position
to start introducing some of the
more advanced Istio features.
We look forward to
seeing how much Istio
simplifies our monitoring
and improves our system
performance.
CHEN GOLDBERG: Wow.
This is awesome to hear.
Thank you, Jeff.
It was such a great
time to work with you
and the team over
the past few years--
few months.
As we continue
and work on Istio,
is there any feedback
or request for us,
so I will take it
back to the team?
JEFF WHITE: Sure.
The Kubernetes
integration is excellent.
CHEN GOLDBERG:
That's good to hear.
JEFF WHITE: The Helm charts
make the installation
a simple one-liner.
The automatic sidecar injection
provides a transparent way
to attach the client proxy.
And the default
Grafana dashboards
provide a great starting
point for monitoring
the critical signals
of the system.
In terms of areas
of improvement,
we look forward to getting
access to more granular data
and controls.
For example, we would
love to be able to slice
and dice our metrics by URL.
We'd also like to
see Istio expose
more sophisticated retry
and time-out configuration
settings.
And of course, we look forward
to a managed Istio service.
CHEN GOLDBERG: Thank
you very much, Jeff.
APARNA SINHA: Thank you.
JEFF WHITE: Thank you.
APARNA SINHA: Thank you, Jeff.
CHEN GOLDBERG: Thanks.
JEFF WHITE: Thank you.
CHEN GOLDBERG: Luckily, we
have all of that recorded,
so we won't forget that.
APARNA SINHA: Thanks.
CHEN GOLDBERG: So we started
with the first principle,
consistent experience.
Consistent experience is often
a trade-off with flexibility.
When you lock things down
to make them consistent,
you limit your options.
As an example, you cannot take a
best-of-breed approach when you
decide to standardize.
We also heard Jeff talk
about the need of having
a platform that evolves as
our requirements continue
to change.
Cloud Services Platform
breaks this trade-off
with a fourth design
principle, flexibility.
Cloud Services Platform is built
on extensible open software.
It comes with an ecosystem and
a pluggable architecture that
gives you flexibility, a choice
of solution, and the ability
to integrate into them
without introducing friction
in the user experience.
If something is missing, you
can fill the gap yourself
without compromising
consistency.
The platform allows you
to evolve as your needs
and requirements change.
We are leveraging Kubernetes
and Istio extensibility
in the rich ecosystem.
So you can customize,
evolve, and integrate
Cloud Services Platform
to better fit your needs.
With that, I'm super
excited to share
that we are the
first major cloud
provider to offer a
production-ready commercial
Kubernetes application
in the GCP marketplace.
Yay!
[APPLAUSE]
It is developed by
third-party partners.
Our commercial
Kubernetes app support,
usage base building,
simplified licensing,
and easy deployment
to Kubernetes Engine
on GCP and everywhere else.
My favorite part about
this announcement
is that all Kubernetes app
listed in the marketplace
are Google-vetted.
That includes vulnerability
scanning and partner agreements
for maintenance and support.
This brings the open Cloud
Services Platform ecosystem
to you wherever you are.
Cloud Services Platform is
a unique hybrid offering
that addresses today's
enterprise challenges where
you are, in the cloud
and on-premises.
In the session today, we focused
on the core platform services.
We introduced the
new GKE On-Prem,
and how it is consistent
with Kubernetes Engine.
The new GKE policy
management, Istio,
together with Stackdriver
and the marketplace,
gives you tools, an
easier way, to manage
this multi-cluster environment.
The key principles of
consistent experience,
centralized control,
agility with reliability,
and flexibility, have stood
the test of time at Google.
And now, with Cloud
Services Platform,
we are making sure
that they support you
through your journey,
without the need
to compromise between them.
We will continue in bringing
more solutions and products
into the Cloud
Services Platform,
based on our years of experience
following the same principles.
Google Cloud is the only
public cloud provider
bringing consistency,
flexibility, control, and speed
of the cloud to your
local data centers,
along with the freedom
of workload portability
to the environment
of your choice.
We are very happy to bring the
cloud, Google's cloud, to you.
APARNA SINHA: Woohoo!
High five!
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you very much
for joining us today.
And thank you so much, Jeff,
for talking about your use
case and your environment.
We hope that we've managed to
pique your interest in Cloud
Services Platform.
There's a lot more.
We didn't have time
to cover everything.
These are some deep
dives tomorrow and on
Thursday that we
would highly recommend
you visit for a
deep dive on Istio,
on GKE On-Prem, and of
course, hybrid use cases.
CHEN GOLDBERG: Thank you.
APARNA SINHA: Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]